this was the last of four graphs that we
were doing ok now I just want to get
across to you whoopsie-daisy just how
mind-blowing it is to me okay that you
can take these three factors and
depending on how you combine them the
things that you get are wildly different
look at their wildly different but
because of this underlying pattern of
how the factors behave and therefore
what signs they produce despite how
different all the ground we had a look
at them right they all have this same
kind of armed skeleton underneath the
vet will follow hey which i think is
awesome this is the last one okay and in
some ways it's though it's the greatest
trickiest one but you can get you can
get up let's have a look at it we've
already factorized it there is no
symmetry to speak of where else
asymptotes down okay so which asymptotes
are generally easier to get which one do
you go for first okay we'll go for the
vertical ones because you can literally
just read them off the denominator right
so when you see the denominator is X
plus one that tells you the vertical
asymptote is x equals negative 1
excellent so there it is right there
okay now at the same time you think i
can do i have a horizontal or do i have
an oblique asymptote now we're trying to
compare the degree of the numerator with
the degree of the denominator degree of
the numerator is 2 and if we're bigger
than one so what kind of acetone we're
gonna have an oblique asymptote okay now
so that we don't get too bogged down I'm
just going to show you what the
opportunity is right now because I've
already calculated and later on after
we've looked at the shape I'll tell you
how to find what the f league asymptote
is I also did the oblique asymptote in
question 2 and we just sort of skipped
over so i'll show you the way in this
casey blake asymptote is X minus 3 okay
so
in order to make it look reasonable on
my graph you can see I haven't drawn it
at a 45-degree angle that's not 45 but
I'd have to make this graph very tall in
order to get it really accurate so we've
got two asymptotes so far yes x minus 3
so i've got x equals negative 1 and y
equals x minus 3 okay we will get into
why that is the case of a second one
okay okay so mistaken identity yeah
after asymptotes SF a I for intercept
okay so what we're looking for our x and
y intercepts right if i let x equal 0
that will give you a y-intercept right
so when I let X equal 0 because i have x
on the numerator I just get I just get 0
right 0 so I'm actually passing users
the origin right that's kind of
convenient because now when I work out
my x-intercepts that's my y-intercept
right when I work out my x-intercepts
turns out I've already got one and the
other one I read off the numerator which
is x equals 2 been there we okay so now
we have all the pieces we have the
asymptotes we add the intercepts worry
about the regions there so where can
this thing go alright so for instance
tell a look at this particular space up
here in this particular space now this
space where my hand is I can rule this
out there's no way the graph can go in
here right I can't approach this absent
touch from the top why not why can't I
go there
yeah yeah that's right sure I would have
to like to come here and have to go up
right and I've got a problem because I
have a vertical asymptote and vertical
asymptotes can't be crossed right there
about domain and restrictions so they
can't be crossed and unlike horizontal
or oblique asymptotes you can cross them
as many times as you like because they
just have to do with the extremities so
therefore i can't i can't come up this
way that means I must be under here okay
which means if I've got these 2's
entrances to stay between there's not
much else I can do about that that's all
I could do okay so I've got that branch
that's nice and i guess if i want to
point for scale so what i would do is i
put the in this is minus 1 so i guess
i'd put in minus 2 which we can quickly
compute this right minus two x minus 4
give me positive 8 and then i divide by
negative 1 so that'll be negative 8
watch it ok so there's my point I'll
just you know negative 2 negative its
approximate okay just if you noticed
before there is a turning point next it
turns around but we don't know we don't
have sophisticated enough stuff to work
out where that Tony party is so I'm just
going to put that close enough all right
now let's see what's going in here okay
I'm obviously going to come down from
here because I've got this vertical
asymptote to approach okay I have to hit
this intercept I'm going to come down
I've got to come back to another
intercept and then I have an asymptote
to approach right so what shape you
guess you how would you describe it okay
okay it's almost kind of the opposite of
this right all hyper blue meanies I
phobos have a kind of symmetry even if
it's not like precise
this is what i'm picturing it's coming
down hitting there and then itch
approach it's approaching that asymptote
over there okay but we kind of shape we
didn't kind of look at it from here you
can see that symmetry there just barely
right so this is different again
different again we've looked at all
these different combinations sometimes
to cross the horizontal or oblique
asymptote sometimes you don't depending
on you know i could put these all the
determinate and get another graph again